we have a voicemail number which is 2192
David P you know I mentioned that it's
interesting that when all of those Mega
people came into the city into New York
City sorry for uh Trump's arrest a few
weeks ago despite all of them claiming
all the time New York City's so
dangerous it's dangerous it's crazy in
New York City we didn't hear about any
of those people that came into the city
for Trump's arrest
even witnessing a single crime never
mind being victimized by it here's a
caller who says he did see a crime when
he was in New York City listen to this
David I I heard you say how you haven't
really witnessed Prime in New York City
and I think you're being a little
disingenuous uh for example a few weeks
ago I was in New York with some friends
and we witnessed a man in broad daylight
being held up and robbed right across
the street and we marveled at it and
then what's really shocking is we were
all arrested for breaking the Good
Samaritan law because we didn't help him
have you ever heard of anything like
this before I mean I have this is a
Seinfeld episode sounds crazy to me my
lawyer said it was Preposterous
ludicrous outrageous I'm still waiting
to you know to get bailed out here so
yeah so that's I'm sure that was
attorney Jackie Childs who said that no
listen I mean
all over New York City not really Staten
Island I've only been there once I just
took the ferry got off and got right
back on but um Manhattan Brooklyn Queens
and the Bronx where I've been to some
Yankees games uh when the Sox are in
town I have never witnessed a single
crime now have I seen mental illness
that sometimes becomes aggressive I have
yeah that's true have I seen bodily
fluids on the subway yes I have uh but
when we're talking about you know the
sort of rampant criminality that the
Wright loves to say is just everywhere
in New York City uh I've never seen it
do I know I mean I guess I know I know
probably someone who's been pickpocketed
or something like that the point is not
to pretend there's no murder in violent
crime in New York City but the point is
when you look at crime rates there's
cities in Ohio with higher crime rates
we know about Oklahoma City Oklahoma
with higher crime rates Etc that's the
point we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today I won't even waste time by
telling you what's on it other than to
say we are going to talk about the
writer's strike the late night comedy
writers strike and many other things
sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access and it will be a beautiful day